[Musique]
avec nous pour en parler bastien lachaud
député est la fille de seine saint denis
pierre fred-lille billets mer et l'air
de dreux et enfin jean la capelle député
européen est reine bonjour bonsoir à
tous les deux joué trois pardon merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
vacciner vacciner vacciner 1 dit et
écrit sur twitter le président c'est
l'obsession du moment sur le terrain la
campagne on l'a vu un vaccination patine
l'exemple du stade de france méga centre
qui a dû être fermée hier une inactivité
forcée faut deux doses une situation
vous avez également vécu à dreux c'est à
frédéric bihet racontez nous ah oui tout
à fait j'ai chanté hier sur tf1 parce
que la ministre pas dire une hache et a
demandé au maire vacciner le dimanche
alors moi je veux bien belle fille née
dimanche a pas de problème sur le camp
n'a pas de dose pour le week-end il
dimanche
on ne peut pas le faire donc s'ils
voulaient c'était une forme aussi
d'agacement de dire nous sommes
interpellés et en tant que mère à dreux
2021 c'est un million d'euros aux
vacciner toute l'agglomération
donc c'est colossal nous nous nous
reprendre en témoin pour me dire
messieurs les maires vacciner de
dimanche
je veux bien mais donnez-moi d2 voilà le
champ d'intervention de ces derniers
jours alors on va essayer de creuser un
petit peu plus parce que c'est
évidemment intéressant ce que vous nous
dites et ça décrit une situation de
terrain qui tranche parfois avec les
effets peut-être d'annonce du
gouvernement bastien la chaux vous le
seine-saint-denis c'est votre
département vous connaissez bien ce
stade de france inaugurée en fanfare par
le gouvernement la semaine dernière
on vient d'entendre défectueux en raison
de la pénurie des vaccins comment
réagissent et habitants sur place
en fait les habitants eux ce qu'ils
demandent c'est pas vaccinodromes parce
que dans le vaccinodromes déjà il est
ouvert très largement beaucoup plus
largement que la seine-saint-denis où on
est déjà un département qui a eu ce
problème là au début de la vaccination
l'essentiel des rendez-vous qui est des
prix sur internet était pris par des
parts des parisiens qui n'avaient plus
de place à paris et qui devait prendre
c'est à dire prendre la place des des
habitants de seine-saint-denis mais en
tout cas les habitants de
seine-saint-denis ne pouvait pas prendre
de rendez vous aujourd'hui on a besoin
que les centres de proximité tourne à
plein régime
et le problème c'est qu'aujourd'hui les
centres de productivité ne tourne pas à
plein régime
moi j'ai fait les chiffres de la semaine
dernière de vaccination en seine saint
denis il y a moins de vaccination en
seine saint denis la semaine dernière
qu'il ya quinze jours et s'éteint c'est
un vrai problème c'est à dire qu'on nous
dit la vaccination la vaccination l'om
il n'ya pas les doses les doses ne sont
pas là moi j'ai interpellé le préfet le
préfet m'a dit mais c'est normal qu'il y
ait moins de premières vaccinations
parce que les doses partent pour les
deuxièmes vaccination dit bon c'est
assez logique et la réalité c'est que
moi j'ai eu donc quand on a repris les
chiffres de la semaine et les premières
injections et le deuxième injection sont
en baisse donc où sont tes dose s'il
n'ya pas dose le gouvernement doit le
dire il ne doit pas de dire on accélère
on accélère en accélère alors que les
deux ne sont pas là le gouvernement a
doit assumer le fait qu' il n'a pas mis
en place la politique nécessaire depuis
un an pour avoir un vaccin français
qu'ils soient produits en france et qui
permet de vacciner
donc aujourd'hui on est dans les mains
des grandes entreprises de pharmacie et
la réalité c'est que ils n'ont donc rien
à faire de nous freezer fournit les
américains aux priorités et des
européens passeront après peut-être un
jour s'il reste des doses et ça c'est
totalement inacceptable c'est la
responsabilité du gouvernement parce que
le président annonce sur twitter
produire produire produire
la seule chose que nous sommes en
capacité de faire aujourd'hui à cause de
son incurie c'est de mettre en flacon
des des fans et des vaccins pfizer et
encore nous ne sommes même pas sûrs que
les doses qui seront mises en jeu la 2d
en france serviront aux français un
véritable problème
oui gens là la capelle votre réaction
quand vous entendez ces deux élus
terrain nous dire voilà séméga sont on
est obligés de les arrêter de toute
façon faute de doses vous vous dit bon
ça va aller mieux il ya 500 dan johnson
qui arrive ou voilà vous perdez un petit
peu espoir où je vous dis quand même que
c'est une ronde pour la sixième
puissance mondiale
que savons nous sommes la risée du monde
l'union européenne est la risée du monde
l'om est-ce avait trouvé inacceptable
notre rythme de vaccination
mais au sein de l'union européenne il ya
encore plus mauvais que tout le monde
sait
la france puisque moi j'ai les chiffres
devant moi nous sommes 9e
proportionnellement par rapport à une
population sur l'injection de la
première dose nous sommes 21e sur la
deuxième dose ce qui est vraiment
inacceptable
mais depuis le départ on a vu qu'il a vu
mais on n'a pas le permis bateau et
c'est un petit peu ça depuis début
d'ailleurs de la crise sanitaire avec le
gouvernement français
on a été très mauvais parce qu'on est co
responsable de cette négociation qui a
mené union européenne qui a voulu être
plus forte que les autres et qui à un
moment donné on vous entend vous vous
êtes un petit peu figé mais on vous
entend donc oui mais tout à fait on vous
entend très bien parfaitement revient
j'ai l'impression que j'en la capelle ne
nous entend plus non l'entendait
parfaitement si on peut lui faire passer
ce message
pierre frédéric billets
l'illustration aussi peut-être de cette
navigation à vue comme nous l'expliqué
jean lain la capelle aujourd'hui on
décide que finalement il y aura un
espacement de deux doses un antre pour
les ex leaders et modern art de 28 jours
à 42 jours alors qu'au départ c'était
non ces changements de cap vous vous les
comprenez on se dit ah bah ça on prend
l'exemple anglais on navigue à vue mais
voilà il faut s'adapter ou ça va
augmenter la défiance delà de la
population ce type de décision alors qui
est vrai fait qu'on voit bien que l'état
trou est fait de trouver des solutions
pour avoir des primo vacciner en plus
grand nombre
la première salve a été de passer de 21
jours à 28 jours pour la seconde dose et
maintenant on passe de 28 jours à 42
jours
c'est aussi un débat scientifique
je comprends la volonté de l'état de
vouloir effet d'élargir le spectre
cela étant c'est pas forcément très
rassurant pour les genres on se pose
beaucoup de questions on voit bien dans
notre de vaccination il ya deux
questions qui viennent
la première fait est-ce que vous avez
della sera donné car du finder ou autres
est une question c'est pourquoi
l'élargissement de cdd entre les deux
doses
tous les ya beaucoup de mes distances de
défiance départ je me suis qui fuit pas
la tâche et on doit faire nous sur le
terrain face à ces demandes qui sont
légitimes
autre illustration d'une certaine
confusion ça se passe en moselle mais ça
explique bien la situation l'ordre des
médecins de moselle qui a exprimé son
incompréhension face à la décision de la
rsc de la préfecture de continuer à
vacciner avec l'astra zeneca alors que
la haute autorité de santé recommande de
ne plus utiliser ce vaccin trop peu
efficace contre le variant sud africain
qui sévit durement dans ce département
on a du mal à suivre tout de même
bastien la chaux que vous inspire cette
petite confusion vous êtes tolérant par
rapport à ça ou vous trouvez ça
finalement impardonnable de la part des
autorités
ce que l'on pouvait accepter il ya un an
devient beaucoup plus compliqué à
accepter aujourd'hui comment voulez vous
que
l'on puisse accepter se décident ce
gouvernement alors que le gouvernement
n'a rien planifié n'a rien anticipé
c'est ça le problème
on ne lui demande pas d'être parfait
mais on lui demande d'anticiper et de ne
pas courir au jour le jour pour trouver
des solutions avec des bouts de ficelle
là aujourd'hui si on est aux jeux obligé
de d'élargir le délai entre les dodos
c'est uniquement parce qu'on n'a pas
assez de doses il fallait produire du
vaccin produit reproduire et on sait le
faire en plus c'est ça le pire c'est que
nous avons des capacités nous avons des
chercheurs nous avons des capacités de
production en pharmacie en 2004 et
aujourd'hui on ne les a pas utilisés
on n'a rien fait et là vous voyez par
exemple on parle du vaccin mais ce qui
est essentiel aussi les questions de
traitement est bien le l'institut
pasteur de lille et travaille sur un
traitement depuis plusieurs mois et il
avait demandé 5 millions d'euros pour
pouvoir avancer sur ce traitement le
gouvernement n'a rien fait c'est lvmh
qui a dû le financer en nature faire
appel le mécénat privé il a aujourd'hui
on découpe que ce vaccin est très
prometteur que le gouvernement le place
comme une des solutions
donc le gouvernement ne planifie pas le
gouvernement d'anticiper le gouvernement
court après la crise
et évidemment cela crée de la défiance
pour les français parce que il ya encore
un mois ont expliqué que si on élargit
ses les doses et bien cela de créer la
possibilité d'avoir des varrio qui se
crée suite à la première injection et
que donc cela pouvait mettre en péril la
stratégie vaccinale est là aujourd'hui
on élargit des doses moi je ne suis pas
scientifique je ne sais pas mais le
problème c'est que aujourd'hui peut-on
faire confiance à la parole du
gouvernement et la parole du
gouvernement est totalement
décrédibilisée dévalorisé et c'est un
vrai problème parce qu'aujourd'hui nous
avons besoin que les gens se fassent
vacciner parce que nous avons besoin
qu'ils méritent et collective
mais comment voulez-vous dire aux gens
allez vous faire vacciner alors que le
tous les pays européens ont des
stratégies différentes sur l'astra
zeneca que deux régions d'une région à
l'autre nous ne faisons pas la même
chose sur l'utilisation de ceux de ce
vaccin
bref aujourd'hui le gouvernement met en
péril la sortie de crise tout simplement
à cause de son impréparation le
gouvernement aussi
qui freine un des cas de faire quand on
se doute nick v berlin en négociations
avec la russie et clément baudelot dit
hier qu en gros c'est un coup de
communication de la part de berlin votre
réaction gens là la capelle oui je vous
y retrouver excusez moi pour cette
petite pique un petit peu figé vous vous
entendez bien néanmoins donc à voilà moi
je suis allé les chercher le salut
parlement européen et vous comprenez
bien qu'ici tout ne fonctionne pas mais
heureusement bien vous en avez lui
serait sans supplémentaires mais pour
répondre à votre question
madame en effet c'est finalement un peu
le préambule que je voulais tout à leur
exprimer
mais le gouvernement a tout raté depuis
le départ ce sera des gis matinale je
parlais de ces négociations
kate avait été fier à ce qu puisque le
parlement européen a souhaité la
commission open a souhaité rendre comme
clef d'entrée le prix dans sa
négociation pour essayer de les
meilleurs que les autres bien finalement
oui ils ont acheté le vaccin parfois un
peu moins cher mais il a délivré les
derniers parce que rien été ficelé
derrière le conte un commercial même pas
ce qui est le b à ba d'un train
commercial même pas les pdt de retard ça
c'était le premier point il a été
mauvais jeu par les français comme qui
ont été d'ailleurs bien moins bon qu'un
certains de leurs voisins européens dans
l'exécution opérationnelle
on n'a pas utilisé l'armé on l'avait
réclamé déjà il ya plusieurs mois on
finit par comprendre que l'armée peut
être utile est d'ailleurs maintenant
elle s'adonne d'hôpitaux vont être
mobilisés et assemble équipe ni les deux
soignants militaire utilisée aujourd'hui
c'est le rattraper le retard terrible
que le gouvernement a pris et puis à
cette gestion de la paie de riz ou
parler d' alternative à nos ruptures à
nos vaccins qui aujourd'hui bien ne sont
pas les livres et approvisionne chez
nous bien oui il ya le spoutnik par
exemple on pourrait commander le
spoutnik
on a le seul où tu as d'état du
gouvernement se fout de nous puisque
depuis mois de décembre en envoyer une
mission gouvernementale en russie et
depuis deux ans il ne se passe rien on
nous dit oui mais y'a rosé sus de
validation d'homologation alors en fait
pour valider astrazeneca ont validé
johnson and johnson pour valider faille
zurich trois semaines mais pour les
russes
il faut 12 mois donc en fait on sent
bien qu ici on se fout de nous on sent
bien que le gouvernement étant conservés
dans des pièges idéologique
aujourd'hui de choisir le prime
this is dans le dogmatisme le fait de la
même manière comme il l'avait fait
rappelez-vous sur la gestion des
frontières et il avait fait se refusant
de suspendre l'ouverture en fin de
support l'ouverture des frontières en
effet de vol qui provenaient de la chine
il le fait pareil pour le brésil parce
que vous savez ce qui se passe au brésil
en ce moment il ya quatre morts cinq
jours justement j'allais y venir
pardonnez moi
les français qui ont découvert que des
avions faisait chaque jour la navette
avec le brésil je rappelle qu'au brésil
il y à plus de 330 milles mort du co
vide avec la propagation d'un variant
très inquiétant d'ailleurs dont on ne
sait pas bien s'il résiste aux vaccins
ou pas clairement pierre frédéric billet
il faudrait fermer les frontières comme
le préconisait d'ailleurs le
rassemblement national dès le début de
l'épidémie il faudrait en tout cas le
faire aujourd'hui fermée au moins ses
liaisons avec le brésil comme le fait le
portugal d'ailleurs alors j'allais
donner l'exemple du portugal mais
globalement effectivement on doit avoir
une politique plus plus défensive pour
nos populations
après je vous donnais l'état d'esprit
que je partage avec beaucoup d'élus
locaux c'est que l'on considère que nous
et le gouvernement nous sommes dans le
même bateau
donc nous sommes sollicités pour mettre
en place les centres de vaccination dès
vaccinodromes quand l'idée pacini 500 da
craint qu'on est tous dans le même
bateau on le fait pour les français pour
la population simplement il faut bien
comprendre qu'il faut nous laisser faire
et sur de vaccination les organise
il faut pas nous imposer d'octo libre à
tous chants il faut ne sait gérer les
rendez vous et surtout ce que j'invite
mois le gouvernement c'est d'être
transparent et clair on fait tous des
erreurs on fait tous des choses comme ça
mais il faut pas raconter des fadaises
ou français quand je vois qu'on annonce
une accélération de la vaccination -
sous les chiffres que je vois
aujourd'hui arrivées de l'année rêve ce
n'est pas la réalité ou qu on est là
pour les français ont fait le maximum
pour nos populations
il faut nous laisser faire des solutions
locales sont souvent les meilleurs
d'ailleurs on l'a vu d'ailleurs sur l'un
de deux thématiques comme le masque de
la vaccination mais nous on demande de
la transparence et de la clarté parce
que c'est nous qui nous sommes et relais
sur le terrain auprès des populations
qui sont inquiètes
je demande un petit peu de calme soyons
transparents et on fera bon an mal an un
bon travail avec eux des français sur
cette fermeture des frontières parce que
c'est inquiète beaucoup de monde un cv
reniant et notamment le brésilien avant
de faire réagir bastien millot écouter
le secrétaire d'état chargé des
transports jean baptiste djebbari qui
donne une explication justement ce n'est
pas la faute du gouvernement
pourquoi est-ce qu'on a gardé ses lignes
parce que s'est imposée par le droit
le conseil d'état nous a dit que les
ressortissants français et les résidents
en france devaient pouvoir continuer à
venir
au nom de la liberté de circulation
bastien à chaud c'est un droit la
liberté de circulation on nous dit à
jean baptiste djebbari il faudrait vous
voulez supprimer céline d'avion
aujourd'hui écoutés déjà où on a fait
une erreur c'est à dire qu'on a laissé
venir le variant britannique sur notre
territoire aujourd'hui on a l'impression
que le gouvernement n'a pas compris la
leçon n'a pas appris la leçon et nous
risquons la même chose avec le variant
brésilien qui est de ce que j'ai pu voir
sur les études scientifiques quelque
chose de largement pire encore que le
variant que le variant britannique moi
je j'ai eu dans ma circonscription des
des ressortissants français qui ont été
bloqués à l'étranger pendant des mois au
début de la crise et personne ne se
soucie et le gouvernement en dernier se
soucier de les faire revenir et de les
rapatrier alors qu' il était en vacances
ils étaient coincés douanes cgc a été on
a dû faire des pieds et des mains pour
pouvoir les faire les faire revenir
parce que les pauvres bougres été
complètement perdus à l'étranger
mais la réalité c'est que moi je ne sais
pas qui qui monte dans ses avions la
vérité c'est que il faut les je ne sais
pas s'il faut fermer les lignes
encore une fois c'est un avis de
scientifiques mais ce qui est certain
c'est ce que demandent les scientifiques
c'est que les gens soient testés à
l'arrivée pourquoi détestons nous pas à
l'arrivée ça c'est quelque chose de
basique
aujourd'hui on a l'impression que l'on
peut venir en france sans aucun contrôle
il s'en est sans aucun test alors moi je
ne sais pas s'il ya tant de français que
ça au brésil pour nécessiter deux vols
quotidiens est donc prêt de près de 600
places j'imagine la taille des avions
il s'est assis à 600 français qui
rentrent du brésil tous les tous les
jours
donc peut-être que l'on peut réduire le
nombre de vols et surtout ce qui est
certain c'est que le doit contrôler
systématiquement et voir imposer des
quarantaines en grande bretagne qui sert
post 14 jours de quarantaine
en france on arrive on a un test pcr de
72 heures avant le vol alors qu'on sait
très bien que les 72 heures c'est pile
le moment où si on est contaminé le
juste après le test et bien on est hyper
contaminants au moment de son arrivée en
france sans symptômes eh bien je ne
comprends pas pourquoi on n'impose pas
des quarantaines pourquoi on n'impose
pas de passer des séjours à l'hôtel aux
hôtels sont vides
en tout cela permettrait de remplir les
hôtels et faire fonctionner l'économie
sur ce tas mais pas trois réponses
d'écouté par mois cela il est
symptomatique là aussi de l'état
d'esprit un petit peu de l'union
européenne vous l'avez par les deux
bandits il ya un danger aujourd'hui qui
provient du brésil y'a qu'à mille morts
par jour 4000 morts par jour c'est à
dire qu'il ya un mort toutes les trois
secondes en ce moment au brésil qui
meurent du variant amazonien où du
variant brésilien est notamment beaucoup
de gens qui sont 50 % des morts au moins
de 45 ans savait que vraiment on est en
train de me c'est un variant qui est
difficilement maîtrisable et qui touche
manière très large
aujourd'hui la population que fait la
france est bien les portes grandes
ouvertes au mois de février la nadière
marine le pen avec la première à envoyer
une lettre une question écrite à
l'assemblée nationale en demandant au
gouvernement de fermer des vols qui
provenaient de la chine
ils ne l'ont jamais fait il a fallu des
mois et des mois un an ou comprendre
enfin que la fermeture des frontières ou
la régulation des frontières elle était
de réguler et de contrôler la
circulation du virus est bien là écoutez
ça se reproduit une nouvelle fois quand
le portugal qui lui a progressé à prix
serrés habitées peu importe ce que
décide l'union européenne au moins quand
tu gagnes appelé sensibilité la france
est encore en baisse dans l'expectative
en fait qu'est ce qu'il faut faire il
faut servez les vols en provenance des
diamants du brésil et puis quand ça
concerne en effet leurs ressortissants
il faut pouvoir les isoler et les mettre
en quarantaine ont 14 ans ce que nous
n'avons jamais fait aujourd'hui vous
promenez vous arrivez du brésil avec un
engagement sur l'honneur et un test pcr
vous entrez chez nous ça n'est pas
normal ça n'est pas normal avec un
lyrisme aussi dangereux que celui là on
le sait qu'avoir de vains mots anglais
eh bien les français qui devraient être
protégés aujourd'hui un gouvernement qui
devrait prendre sa solidité
et bien finalement n'y arrive pas on
nous a vendu une grande
de la santé une grande europe de la
protection on se rend compte
qu'aujourd'hui mais ça n'est pas le cas
et maquereau est responsable cela de
tout ça très grave s'il a été élu par
les français pour qu'ils soient protégés
mais c'est tout le contraire pour des
raisons idéologiques pour des exemples
dogmatisme alors qu'on lui demandait de
fatick pierre frédéric amiel le mot de
la fin pour vous quand emmanuel macron
nous promet un plan de réouverture d'ici
la mi mai c'est à dire quoi dans allez
un petit mois vous y croyez
écoutez en guise de conclusion je veux
dire deux choses le contrôle des
frontières est une chose importante
on est en plein confinement de l'autre
côté on met beaucoup de pression sur les
français et pour que il respecte toutes
ces règles et l'autre côté on accueille
des gens qu'il est du brésil ailleurs
sans trop de contrôles on comprenait que
cette espèce de de mécanique à deux
vitesses à peu un peu agacé des français
première chose et puis la seconde chose
c'est que il faut absolument qu'on sorte
de cette épisode qui est quand même très
malheureux n'oublions pas que derrière
cette crise il y à des commerçants des
restaurateurs de l'emploi des gens qui
font détresse mentale qui font des très
économique nous localement avec nos
petits mois on était de faire le maximum
pour les aider mais il faut offrir
aujourd'hui la lisibilité j'espère que
l'animé les restaurants pourront ouvrir
j'ai fait les bacs intrants et des
surnombres
dès qu'on aura un début de feu tunnel je
vous assure que nos restaurateurs nos
commerçants les chefs d'entreprise il
faut en pleine dépression
moi ça m'inquiète beaucoup la reprise va
être là j'espère un très rapidement mais
moi j'appelle aussi gouvernement à bien
réfléchir sur des messages qui vont
passer dans les prochains jours
vis-à-vis de nos chefs d'entreprise
commerçants rien qui merci en tout cas
tous les trois à merci bastien la chope
hier après des rivier
et jenlain avec appel d'avoir été avec
nous en direct sur rt france